so first of all congratulations on the
Grey Cup hey this is really cool how did
you but what was your reaction when you
found out that you got the gig it's like
oh my gosh well I done it well I didn't
didn't do like the halftime thing the
last last year two years ago or was it
lasted um I did like the I just like
saying in the opening or whatever but
this is like a totally different thing
it's like the Canadian version of a
Super Bowl in a way but it was cool
really cool I think my dad was more
excited than me even because he's like
obviously a huge sports fan but it's so
cool very intimidating to know that like
millions of people are gonna be watching
you lives but hopefully everything will
go well I'm sure well you were you were
with a should I at the CMAs Hamilton did
you guys talk about it at all like about
how do you navigate through the halftime
show no we didn't I should have asked no
we didn't I really like we just got
rushed off stage you know how those
things are and then after that we talked
for like two seconds and took a picture
and then I had we had to she had to
leave and go on stage again so I didn't
get to talk to her but maybe I can find
her online I'll ask her so it has a big
sports fan does any of that rub up on
you are you like do you have any teams
that you follow are you excited to see
them play honestly I'm not I I really
don't know much about sports to be
honest I'm I mean no I'm really not but
it still is gonna be fun cuz I like the
idea of sports I like the spirit of
sports and it's always been huge in my
family I just don't know a lot about it
but
it'll be fun to be perfectly honest I'm
the same way I would be more excited to
know that you're actually performing
half time and that's what I would be
tuning in for yeah thank you
yeah so let's talk about the pains of
growing now they say you've got your
entire life to come up with your first
album in like five minutes to come up
with your follow-up album did you feel
that um yeah actually it kind of does
well in a way yeah because I think the
second album and with with the second
album there's a lot of anticipation that
wasn't necessarily there the first time
around because you know when it's your
first album if it doesn't do well no one
would know because no one knows you yet
but like in this case people are
expecting something from you and you
know they've created a label for you on
the first album that kind of like I
think transcends to the others where
they expect you to be the same I guess
or Izzy they're like stay the exact same
or expand yourself in the right way
which is very difficult because
self-expression I think is kind of broad
and it should be fun but I don't know on
the other end though I think my fans are
my fans because of the person I am and
my honesty so as long as I do that I
think I mean I'm not worried yeah
how are you dealing with that that
expectation I mean you said you know
they want to label you immediately and
say oh this is the kind of artist that
you are when inside like I'm not sure
how you feel inside but you probably
have all these different aspects of you
that you want to show and share right
definitely yeah of course I think
because um my last few songs were about
positivity and like whether it's like
body image or mental health and things
like that people have just like labeled
me as this person who's always positive
trying to spread light which of course I
am but there are so many different
facets to me and I'm not always positive
I think you know I have these giant
chunks of time where I am sad and I go
through things like everybody else and
I'm confused and this and that so I
definitely want to start talking about
that more because I'm definitely not
always happy and I don't think that's
always a good message to send anyway
like always be happy you know because
sometimes you have to you have to feel
things you have to go through moments
where you're not always on in order to
get stronger and to grow so
100% as I understand a lot of the music
in this album comes from like the
conflicting emotions that you've had
over the last few years mixed emotions
something has to do with a with a
breakup that you had recently then this
is your ex heard any of the music that
might be about yeah everybody everybody
I write about hears it before I put it
out just because it's like I choose to
write these things but they don't choose
to have you know aspects of their life
in a song so like everybody I write
about whether it's even like my parents
or my brother like even small lines I
always say like is this okay so yes he's
heard of everyone's heard them is it
more nerve-wracking to share that you
know those lines of those songs with the
people that are close to you more so
than all the millions of strangers
that'd be listening a little bit yeah it
actually is because I guess that you
don't really know all the strangers and
you don't you don't have to watch them
listening but usually when I play
something for somebody close to me I'm
usually there with them or they give me
direct feedback and you know it's like
you're you're opening up in a way that
you might not have like just by talking
to them so then like a lot of the songs
for Milo and I play them for my parents
it's like they were finding out things
that I don't ever really say to them so
which is like weird or like whether it's
a the relationship or things like that
like that's how I express myself so I
might have jotted down some things that
I actually never said which can be kind
of scary but with regards to to that
acts like how does he take the music was
surprised like what was the emotional
state uh I don't know I guess well I
don't know if he was lying I said he
said he likes it a lot I don't know if
they're I mean I don't know if anyone's
lying when they I don't I trust him I
trust everybody that I that's like close
to me and we're still we're still really
close I think you like they I don't I
don't I don't ever like write songs to
to be mean or say things like I just
write how I feel so I hope it's not like
offensive to anybody who do you trust
like that's close to you to be honest
with you about your music about the
views that you're putting out to tell
you like hmm I'm not feeling that hook
or whatever um I usually I usually send
them to my best friend
who usually like she has like a really
good ear and she has really good music
taste I think so I always trust her and
my parents honestly and my manager I
have like just my core group of people I
really just trust their ear in their
opinion so I'll try to like show them
everything yeah that core group is so
important yeah are you ever concerned
about I just get bigger and you go on in
your career sort of losing focus losing
who you are and who you've wanted to be
I mean I guess sometimes it can be it
can be easy to be skewed one way or
another when you're in this industry but
I think I'm such a stubborn person to be
honest or if people try to tell me to do
something or be something I'm not I'm
gonna like do the opposite even more to
prove why they're wrong you know so in
that sense I mean I don't really fear it
it is like something that you kind of
have to battle with every day cuz you're
gonna have all these voices and opinions
and things like that but I'm not worried
of changing because I feel like I have a
strong idea of at least who I am I don't
know a lot of things and I'm still
figuring out a million and one things
about myself but I Know Who I am and
that's the most important thing do you
feel like you're living your dream right
now yeah definitely and more I didn't
even know what that dream entailed I
just knew I wanted to do music you know
so there's so much more that comes with
that that I didn't even know I loved so
yeah definitely you speak to your fans
so personally on your music and they
they connect to you so closely what do
you say to you two young girls that
might feel discouraged from following
their dreams man I felt like that for so
long you know and I think there's like
this weird stigma around doing a job
that's like not necessarily common or
things like that and people always just
tell you like if you're not going to
school if you're not doing this like you
can't you can't achieve it it's not
tangible it's not real but I always
thought well if there are people doing
it and I can be one of those people you
know it's not like it's a job that
nobody does there are people real-life
human beings that are doing it so I
would say just never rule out the idea
that you could
be one of those people think just work
really hard and what we need to realize
is we all have a purpose whether we
think so or not and I just happen to
find mine sooner in life which is
amazing but everyone you'll find yours
and don't listen to what people say
about like oh this isn't it if you feel
something in your heart you got to go
for it even if it doesn't work out your
life always works itself out in the end
so what's going on with your with your
suit today this might fit that might fit
me actually yeah I know I know it's very
a lot of people just think that I it's
just a poor fashion choice or like I
sized it wrong yes I know it's large
it's I wanted to symbolize the idea of
growth or the metaphor of feeling
sometimes too small for the role that
was thrown at you in life you know so I
thought of a way to do that visually and
I thought well when you think like grown
up like the caricature version of grown
up you think like business suit and
stuff you know so I wanted to like build
up this character which is pretty much
me and I think all of us when we grow up
sometimes and and just symbolize the
idea of like grow growing up too fast
and feeling kind of too small or like
you're kind of drowning in life
sometimes that is the cool i 100% feel
that way every time i put on the suit
yeah